[Music]
burglars vampires and sex games gone
wrong cannibals and werewolves collide
in a dark cave and all the slashers from
the 80s come in for a huge party did you
notice these creepy connections
throughout all three films that make up
the evil dead trilogy and the tv series
ash vs evil dead creator sam raimi
weaves in a number of references to
iconic horror movies the most notable
being a direct tie-in to wes cravens a
nightmare on elm street in a brief blink
and you'll miss it moment eagle-eyed
fans can spot the iconic bladed glove of
freddy krueger in the workshed sequence
in evil dead 2. if that weren't enough
freddy's glove also appears in a
similarly small capacity in ash vs evil
dead still hanging in the work shed when
ash returns to the cabin decades after
the events of evil dead 2. according to
esquire the explanation behind the
appearances of freddie's glove in the
film and raymie's tv series dates back
to a friendly game of one upmanship
between raymie and craven noticing a
torn poster for jaws in the background
of craven's the hills have eyes raymie
decided to include a poster for the
hills have eyes in his first evil dead
movie as if to hint that raymie's film
was scarier than craven's in turn craven
included a scene from the evil dead in a
nightmare on elm street prompting rainey
to include freddie's famous glove in
evil dead too now this is the sort of
friendly banter and competition that
fans love to see between filmmakers
[Music]
a nightmare on elm street isn't the only
horror franchise that the evil dead
series ties into in the 9th entry of the
friday the 13th series jason goes to
hell the final friday the movie's
director included several props from the
evil dead films that seemed to connect
his film with raymie's horror series in
jason goes to hell items like the
candarian dagger and the necronomicon ex
mortis from the evil dead are
prominently shown with one character
even momentarily flipping the pages of
the necronomicon rather than it being a
simple tribute like the inclusion of
freddy's glove in evil dead 2 the
director of jason goes to hell made it
very clear that the link runs much
deeper than a mere visual reference in
fact it was his attempt at ensuring
these two franchises would be linked
forever in an interview with horror
geeklife director adam marcus said the
appearance of the necronomicon is meant
to non-verbally establish that jason
voorhees mother pamela read from the
book in order to raise her son from the
dead as marcus sees it such an
explanation helps provide a feasible
reason as to why jason goes from a young
boy to an unstoppable killing machine by
the second friday the 13th film in other
words he simply has to be a deadite
marcus fully supports his self-created
fan theory telling naysayers it's now
canon and that's final
taking a more comedic approach to the
slasher genre bride of chucky is known
for acting almost as an outright spoof
of slashers than anything else poking
fun at numerous horror movies of its day
slasher fans can spot any one of the
large number of references the movie
makes to well-known horror films however
the most straightforward example of this
being in the movie's opening moments the
scene in question finds tiffany
valentine hiring a corrupt police
officer to retrieve chucky's remains
from police custody venturing into the
department's evidence locker room the
police officer passes several artifacts
of slasher fame these include michael
meyer's white mask from halloween
jason's hockey mask from friday the 13th
and freddy krueger's blade-fingered
glove from a nightmare on elm street
there's also a chainsaw that may be the
property of either ash from evil dead or
leatherface from the texas chainsaw
massacre series i think i prefer you
like this
you're kind of cute
sharknado is a horror series that falls
under the umbrella term so bad it's
actually kind of good consisting of
sequels prequels spin-offs and even
video games and comics the sharknado
franchise is known for its laughably
poor effects its over-the-top acting and
its endless supply of celebrity cameos
like every entry in the franchise
sharknado the fourth awakens is no
exception to this latter rule one of the
minor characters to appear in the film
is taken straight out of texas chainsaw
massacre ii the radio dj best known as
stretch surviving her run-in with the
cannibalistic sawyer family stretch goes
on to appear in sharknado once again
played by carolyn williams in a small
but entertaining cameo appearance by the
events of sharknado stretch has settled
down fittingly opening a chainsaw store
with her friend choptop played by dog
the bounty hunter the concept of a
chainsaw store is an obvious reference
to william's starring role in texas
chainsaw massacre too however the name
of dog's character also serves as a
clever nod to the film sharing his name
with the member of the villainous sawyer
clan who menaces stretch
since his debut film reservoir dogs
quentin tarantino has created one of the
most layered filmographies of any
director working today mastering a range
of diverse styles and genres as
drastically different as each of his
movies are almost all of tarantino's
films have been revealed to exist within
one massive shared universe known as the
tarantino verse in certain cases the
connections between tarantino's films
may be something as small or they could
be larger such as a character who
crosses over into other films one great
example of this is his southern law man
sheriff earl mcgraw played by regular
collaborator michael parks who appeared
in several tarantino-related films
introduced in the tarantino pinned from
dusk till dawn mcgraw seemingly meets
his end at the hands of the fugitive
gecko brothers at the start of the film
however the character went on to appear
in a handful of other tarantino films
including kill bill and death proof as
well as robert rodriguez's planet terror
meaning that each one of these films
exist within the same universe does
anybody know what's going on here
there is a major connection that places
joe dante's the howling and the iconic
slasher franchise in the same universe
this connection can be spotted in walter
paisley's occult bookstore with the
mummified remains of a woman spotted in
the background a more careful look at
the body reveals that this is actually
the corpse of great grandma sawyer from
the texas chainsaw massacre ii as the
mummy is spotted in a bookstore
primarily dealing with the occult it
shouldn't be surprising that a notorious
figure like the sawyers matriarch found
its way into paisley's macabre
collection more than likely grandma
sawyer's appearance in the film can be
explained by the fact that the howling
production designer bob burns also
worked on the texas chainsaw massacre
likely using props he already had on
hand from that film to stock paisley's
bookstore
still it's interesting to wonder what a
universe where leatherface battles
werewolves and what the resulting
carnage that would ensue from such an
epic encounter would look like
in addition to its connection with toby
hoopers the texas chainsaw massacre the
howling also happens to tie into another
of director joe dante's works in the
werewolf film a news anchor named lou
landers appears briefly seemingly named
in part for the director of the bela
lugosi starring the return of the
vampire in dante's follow-up movie
gremlins lou landers reappears in a
minor capacity this time reporting on
the mogwai invasion of kingston falls
the connection is a small one but it's
still interesting to see landers appear
in a manner that ties the two dante
directed films together aside from
lander's appearance in both films there
is a small visual connection that
further links dante's two movies in a
small scene in gremlins a yellow smiley
face sticker appears on the pelzer's
family's refrigerator this can be seen
as a reference to the calling card of
eddie quist a serial killer in the
howling who leaves behind smiley face
stickers at the locations of his past
murders it's subtle but it's easily
noticeable to fans of both films having
fun in the decades following the release
of jaws dozens of films have tried to
cash in on that landmark movie's success
by depicting everyday animals as
uncharacteristically aggressive
man-eaters the most notable of these
jaws rip-offs is joe dante's piranha the
movie that led to the director's
meteoric rise in hollywood receiving
mixed reviews at the time of its release
the film went on to achieve cult status
in the years that followed it led to a
sequel and two remakes one of which was
released in 2010 as piranha 3d coming
full circle with the undeniable
influence of jaws on the film piranha 3d
opens with an elderly fisherman being
devoured by a school of ravenous
piranhas emerging from an underwater
cave played by richard dreyfuss the
fisherman appears to be wearing an
identical outfit the one worn by his
character matt hooper and jaws as it
turns out this was not an accident but
an intentional effort to establish the
fact that dreyfuss is playing the same
character in both films as dreyfuss told
hollywood news i play the older matt
hooper who escaped being eaten by the
shark and is now eaten by a bunch of
piranha fish
they're all gonna die
filmmaker mike flanagan has cultivated
quite an impressive reputation as a
modern horror director tackling several
ambitious adaptations of stephen king's
work and helming some of his own equally
entertaining original projects a link
between two of the director's best
projects can be found in his 2017
netflix thriller gerald's game based on
king's novel of the same name in the
film the main character jessie is left
chained to a bed while getting intimate
with her husband who suddenly passes
away from a heart attack as jessie
searches for ways to free herself from
her handcuffs viewers can see a book on
a shelf above jessie's bed in several
scenes the book titled midnight mass is
written by maddie young maddie is also
the name of the main character of
flanagan's previous film hush as if that
weren't a powerful enough connection the
title of maddie's book would even serve
as a premonition for flanagan's later
effort midnight mass which is an
excellent horror miniseries in its own
right you're so much smaller than i
remember
director neil marshall is responsible
for delivering some of the most vastly
underrated horror movies of the past few
decades two of which include his
wonderful werewolf film dog soldiers and
his claustrophobic horror shocker the
descent as vastly different as the two
movies are they do share common threads
that place them within the same
nightmarish universe the connection
between the two films can be seen in the
descent when the film's main character
sarah looks over the various skeletal
remains of past meals devoured by the
carnivorous creatures living in the
underground cave system in the scene
sarah briefly scans over what looks like
the head of a giant werewolf from
marshall's previous film dog soldiers in
another minor scene in the film sarah
picks up an old helmet with the name
oswald written across it that she finds
in the underground cave this serves as
another tie-in to dog soldiers
referencing a close friend of that
film's chief protagonist harry g wells
whom he reminisces about in the film
while wells reveals that oswald met his
end via a landmine in the iraq war it's
worth wondering if he'd maybe ventured
into the same cave system shown in the
descent some time before his gruesome
demise perhaps that could be a prequel
film idea for marshall to consider
you